hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled a novel blood-based
biomarker for silent cerebral edema and
brain vascular injury this webinar is
part of the neuroscience 2021 and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
the lab roots and sponsored by luminix
for more information about luminix
please go to www.luminexcorp.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during this presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation and if you have any
trouble hearing or seeing this
presentation simply click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker dr jason hinman an
associate professor and vice chair of
research in the department of neurology
at the david geffen school of medicine
at ucla
welcome dr henry you can join us now and
begin your presentation
thank you susie and good morning
everyone i'm glad you're able to join us
uh i'm going to tell three interesting
stories today
and try to convince you first
about why we should be caring about
silent brain vascular injury
second some work from my laboratory
trying to identify new molecular
pathways that can lead us to therapies
and diagnostics for
brain vascular injury and thirdly
the work we've done using a luminex
platform to identify a novel blood-based
biomarker that can measure
silent cerebral edema and brain vascular
injury
i have relevant disclosures regarding
grant funding and some of the work we've
done today has been patented by the
university of california
cerebral small vessel disease is
a frustrating entity
as a clinician
it is a chronic and progressive disease
of brains small vasculature
usually the
micron sized arterioles and capillaries
that
make up the majority of the blood supply
in the brain
occlusion of these small blood vessels
accounts for about a quarter of all
strokes in the united states annually
and uh
the
damage to the brain
the these small blood vessels can occur
in in several different manners or
patterns the first is you can have a
lesion like this one here in the upper
left mri picture
where you have an acute subcortical
ischemic event
also known as a stroke
and if it's localized to the correct
portion of the brain
it leads to clinical symptoms that may
bring one to the emergency room
there is a
and again that accounts for about a
quarter of all strokes in the u.s
annually
there is a another much larger portion
of patients in which those lesions are
occurring but they happen to be
occurring in portions of the brain that
one is not using regularly
and those uh are often referred to as
silent or
diffuse white matter lesions that appear
on mri scans often done for another
reason headache or
other things
and with the advent of increasing power
and mri signals we now recognize that
these tiny infarcts can occur as here in
the upper right uh far-right mri image
in a very small arterial that perfuse
the surface of the brain we call those
cortical micro infarcts
as i mentioned the
the the prevalence estimate of these
types of lesions particularly the latter
two far exceed the number of patients
who come to the emergency room with a
small vessel ischemic stroke
and it's estimated that these may be
occurring as
as many as one to two million times a
year
in individuals but without clinical
symptoms they're not coming in for care
immediately
over time though these clinical these
lesions accumulate the clinical symptoms
then become
cognitive impairment dementia
dysfunctionality and gait and other
types of symptoms so there's a very
frustrating clinical entity because it's
hard to measure
uh it has a significant impact though
and
one thing we know is that these lesions
go up with
age substantially
i'm showing data from a a significant
meta-analysis done
indicating that much like alzheimer's
disease or other neurodegenerative
diseases
this uh
damage that occurs silently to the brain
increases as one goes into the sixth
seventh eighth and onward decades of
life
and
we know that they also significantly
increased the risk of having a stroke
i'll show you some data on that it's
about three and a half times normal
and we also know that they increase the
risk of dementia by disrupting brain
conductivity
so first the data on how these lesions
increase the risk of stroke
this again data from a prominent
meta-analysis
in which um
the estimate
of
folks who have white matter lesions is
silent ischemic damage
uh who who subsequently uh have a risk
for stroke is approximately three and a
half times
you can see that was fairly consistent
across studies and even higher in
populations that were characterized as
high risk and we'll talk about those in
a moment
uh
if one has
these white matter
ischemic lesions in the brain you're
much more likely when having occlusion
of one of those vessels to have symptoms
persistent symptoms that would be
classified as a stroke as opposed to
transient symptoms that resolve are what
we call a tia
so you increase the likelihood of your
symptoms progressing to actual ischemic
damage to the brain if you have these
baseline microvascular injuries
similarly the size of one stroke is also
increased and this is data from the
group in mgh from some years ago in
which they were able to track the
progression of this of a stroke over the
first 12 days
in patients with or without
these
ischemic white matter lesions and what
you can see from the
the the
left dwi images that over time in the
presence of these
uh
white matter ischemic lesions the
infarct becomes much larger and it
fills in the area of low brain perfusion
that was present on the initial scan
as opposed to not having uh these
underlying lesions
and importantly
in patients receiving acute thrombolysis
or mechanical thrombectomy as a
treatment for stroke
in the presence of these white matter
ischemic lesions
the outcome
90 days after the stroke is much
much more
significant than
and the treatment less successful than
if you do not have these lesions
and so they clearly have an impact on
stroke both the diagnosis the risk the
the
likelihood of progressing to clinical
symptoms size of one stroke and the
ultimate treatment outcome
similarly
these white matter lesions
significantly increase the risk of
dementia
this is a population-based study looking
purely at the risk of stroke
and its association with
an increased risk of dementia you can
see that even in folks who have a small
uh stroke uh in the
tia in the very lightest line along the
bottom of the graph
or in the line just above that a fairly
minor stroke is judged by clinical
symptoms
there's still a substantial 10 to 15
sometimes out to five years 20 risk
of progressing to a clinical dementia
and
this isn't this is not clearly
understood
but one reason that a small stroke could
attribute to this phenomenon is evidence
by by this this work uh from uh
colleagues in europe
uh i showed you two examples of the
stroke lesions the small one that occurs
acutely
uh or the the
numerous ones that it couldn't come
across silently but in a group of
patients that are have a monogenic
disorder called catastyl that are
inevitably going to get these smaller
stroke lesions like that that pictured
in the upper left mri
and if you follow those patients over a
year because of their monogenic
condition they're
inevitably getting these lesions and you
employ modern mri techniques like
tractography
you can identify the areas of the cortex
that
those axons supply
and what you see is that after a small
infarct like that even though it's
occurred in the deep portion of the
brain
the manifestation
can also affect the cortex where you see
thinning of the surface of the brain the
connected region that was impacted by
the the subcortical stroke
and so this is a the idea behind how
these types of small lesions can still
have a lasting and significant impact
on the brain
they have that distant effect but they
also have this unique feature
of local progression
uh again in that same series of patients
who get inevitable progressive lesions
it's a useful cohort to follow over time
and what we see when we do that is that
new lesions
like that pictured in the right mri scan
in the upper left
tend to occur within regions where
they've already been damaged as
evidenced by the bright white signal and
mri so this leads to a model then where
new lesions are appearing at the leading
edge or the penumbral
edge of the
of the vascular damage
there's been some elegant work from
colleagues at uc davis
showing that
in patients who have these white matter
hyperintensities
the the the most
uh easily measurable
uh mri metric of connectivity uh
diffusion tensor imaging
also drops out in that region just where
the
white matter hyperintensities occur at
the leading edge
my lab has done some work to
characterize
the these abnormalities using human
pathology specimens
and what we see is
uh in pathology this is the typical sort
of lesion that occurs in the brain after
uh uh
one of those small strokes you get a
so-called lacunar infarct this is where
the the lake of csf fluid that fills in
in the necrotic core and you get a
penumbral region adjacent to that where
there's damage
when you characterize
uh and so what we did was use immunohis
chemistry to look at the integrity of
myelin and axons
in that region
and what you see
particularly looking at the the
ultrastructure
of axons which can be characterized by
molecular markers like
voltage-gated sodium channels that label
the node of ranvier and adjacent
paranormal segments
where the myelin makes contact with the
axon
and what you see is when you look in the
region
just adjacent to the stroke is that in
in normal turing brain you get this nice
bow type pattern as you see in the
diagram top
but in the
region adjacent to the stroke pictured
in the right center you see that the
both the nodal and paranormal segments
elongate consistent with a breakdown of
the normal structure of axons
in that penumbral region we quantified
that showing that even if you go a
significant distance away from that
core lesion uh you you still have
abnormalities and axons that are present
uh some distance away from the infarct
itself
uh and we show that this phenomenon is
also true
in a related uh series of patients with
um again monogenic
uh
uh
ischemic disease uh and
get who get these patchy lesions
throughout their brain white matter and
they have similar elongations of axonal
microdomains uh in the adjacent region
so it's a progressive phenomenon that
has
both local
and distant uh impacts on the brain
now one thing we recognize is that
vascular risk factors are one of the
conditions in which these lesions tend
to get worse
so beyond age we also see a substantial
increase when we look at
the association of stroke these white
matter lesions and vascular risk first
we'll look at the association of stroke
and it occurs at multiple different
levels
first it occurs at the epidemiologic
level on the top you see in purple a map
of stroke rates across the us and you
can see a relatively increased risk in
what is termed the stroke belt
uh in the southeast
uh in orange you see a map of rates or
incidents of diabetes across the u.s
and you can uh it doesn't take much to
hallucinate that these maps overlap
significantly with each other and in the
bottom right you see a map of obesity
rates across the u.s and again similar
shared patterns across high-risk
patients
this uh data is from a very nice paper
looking at the risk of stroke and
cardiovascular outcomes associated with
type 2 diabetics with or without risk
factor control and so what you can see
in the graph is that as
glycated hemoglobin systolic blood
pressure and
cholesterol levels ldl cholesterol
levels increase to the right you see
their risk or hazard ratio of having a
stroke
goes up substantially nearly doubling in
some cases
and then similar to what i showed
earlier
folks who have these vascular risk
factors don't do well even when treated
and so this is the risk of a poor
outcome if you have high blood sugar
upon presentation
for treatment with a stroke
nearly doubling the risk of a bad
outcome
and
again we see that the risk of ischemic
white matter disease is further
accelerated in the presence of these uh
vascular risk factors so i showed this
figure earlier the risk of a stroke in
the high-risk population defined in this
study as folks who had uncontrolled
vascular risk factors like high blood
pressure and diabetes
the
rate is
risk of a stroke is even
higher
and we know that uh in this data the
risk of uh the progression of ischemic
white matter lesions goes up similarly
whether you
in the presence of hypertension in fact
whether it's controlled or not
controlled
a condition
that is a constellation of vassar risk
factors in obesity called metabolic
syndrome uh also increases the
progression or or detection of these
ischemic white matter relations
in the brain
and um and again here just a table again
emphasizing the same point the risk of a
new lacunar stroke as evidenced on mri
as i showed examples of earlier
goes up substantially nearly doubling
with specific vascular risk factors
so it's a lot of data in this area and
there's been a lot of research interest
if you do a pubmed search for white
matter hyperintensities
another term for the ischemic brain
vascular injury i showed early on
it's it's gone up exponentially in the
last
decade
however it's not translated yet to
specific
treatments designed to target this
particular entity of cerebral small
vessel disease the best clinical data is
a relatively routine
addition of
clopidogrel to aspirin
for patients with this type of brain
disease and that trial was negative with
no added benefit of the addition of a
second anti-platelet drug
so
this has been frustrating and the
national institutes of health has made a
tremendous investment in trying to do
better to understand neurovascular
contributions
to
aging
age-related cognitive impairment and and
the risk associated with
a
progression of cognitive disease in
patients with
stroke diagnoses i'm highlighting here
several of the substantial investments
that nih has made in understanding what
is now called vascular cognitive
impairment and dementia or vcid just in
the last 10 years
even last five years
nih has invested 50 million dollars in a
multi-site consortium called mark vcid
i'll tell you about that in a moment
we've been fortunate to be involved in
that
uh with the goal of identifying specific
imaging and fluid biomarkers to pick up
this silent brain vascular injury
we're also participating in a large
study that i'll tell you about at the
end of our talk today
to identify how a stroke impacts the
risk of dementia
afterwards and then another study
headed by uc davis and colleagues uh
called diverse vcid which is
specifically looking at
how these
lesions vary in diverse
clinical populations
uh and we've been very fortunate to be
involved in in the mark bcie consortium
which of those three is
moving along most significantly and the
purpose here is to really identify
molecular uh biomarkers imaging and
molecular biomarkers that can function
at the interface between stroke and
alzheimer's disease an area termed
vascular cognitive impairment
and it's a seven site consortium and
we've been participating as a west coast
group with colleagues at several other
ucs
now now what's the point why should we i
mean i tried to show you the evidence
that it's important to care about
ischemic white matter disease because it
does so much to damage the brain and
increase the risk of stroke and dementia
but you know biomarkers are they're
interesting but they can be very noisy
and so why should we care what impact
will it have clinically
and to that we need to just step one
quickly back and look at the alzheimer's
field
if we look briefly at the all centers
field i'll give two examples but the
first is from a study that looked at
amyloid scanning a new technique to
measure brain amyloid
via pet scanning
expensive undertaking some risk
associated with the uh
with the study
but
medicare really wanted to know if they
should be considering paying for such a
such a study
and in this beautifully organized
study
what they were able to show is that
increased diagnosis
through in this case imaging biomarker
resulted in a management change in over
60 percent of patients
and in fact the diagnosis changed in
nearly 35 percent of those patients
so there's clear evidence that that
adding more information to a relatively
noisy area can be particularly helpful
clinically
similarly if we look specifically at
vascular risk factors the uh again uh
really impressive sprint trial that
looked at the control of blood pressure
aggressive controlled blood pressure
versus standard control
resulted in a reduced risk of
uh cognitive impairment with aggressive
uh risk factor control and so there's
reason to uh identify and and do better
and
using biomarkers
all right so we'll move on to the second
part of the talk and i'll tell the
second story and my laboratory focuses
on identifying the molecular pathways
that we can use that are relevant to
this disease
and how we can use them to
improve treatment and diagnosis
my lab uses several approaches to
address this one is we try to
model chronic supervascular risk
and understand
the molecular pathways that are
associated with that
we have several models that we use in
the lab in which we can introduce a
small stroke lesion like the one i
showed in human pathology early on
and we can use that model
to understand molecular pathways that
are active in the stroke
we're collectively combining that to
identify new therapeutic approaches and
i'll show you a limited set of data on
that
and importantly we think it's really
important to take all of that
rodent and basic work and apply it to
the human condition because that's
really what we're interested in trying
to solve
and so we always work to try to validate
our model findings in humans and our
basic science story that i'm about to
tell you will ultimately lead to
some
work
in humans to try to validate our
findings
so one way we get at those molecular
pathways in the lab is to use a
technique called translating ribosome
affinity purification this is a
technique some may be familiar with in
which you can add
antigenic tags to ribosomes and that can
be really helpful for a noisy cellular
tissue like the brain where you have
multiple different cell types
and it's hard to
get at the very specific cellular
molecular programs that might be active
and it has several advantages even over
single cell sequencing in that you're
getting mrna messages that are
specifically associated with ribosomes
so on their way to being translated
and you can by that technique you
usually get substantial uh
increased sequencing depth that can
really
inform
for low abundance proteins
so what we did was uh try to take that
translating ribosome affinity
purification technique and see if we
couldn't apply it to endothelial cells
in the setting of a chronic
factor and we chose to use obesity for
several reasons one i showed you the
maps rates in the us are going up
substantially there's a significant
overlap with the risk of stroke and and
certain vascular disease
and it's fairly simple to model in the
laboratory you place mice with a
specific genetic background
on a high calorie diet they get very
overweight as shown in the picture
the graft and demonstrates the weight
over time increase and the table here
shows that they develop a serum profile
it looks very much like many of the
patients
uh in which there's hyper
triglyceridemia high cholesterol
uh elevated levels of glucose and and
they get a low-grade hypertension uh
which i'm not showing here but it's been
well established before
and so what we did then was use this
novel mouse strain we created uh called
the endotag mouse
where we used an endothelial cree driver
together with the
ribotag mouth to label uh
ribosomes with an antigenic ha tag
specifically in endothelial cells you
can see that here in the in the picture
below just an image of the brain uh
where the blood vessels are labeled in
red and the um ribosomes are labeled in
green and you can see that there's
intense ribosomal labeling within the
endothelial cells
then we took those that strain and place
those animals on the high fat diet and
then isolated the white matter
pulled down the uh ha tagged ribosomes
via immunoprecipitation
and then
sequenced the rna associated with those
ribosomes and the uh the heat map here
shows that we specifically enrich for
endothelial transcripts using this
technique
and the volcano plot shows the number of
genes that were up and down regulated uh
in the white matter and ideal cells
in this disease profiling and i draw
your attention specifically to two
molecules that are pictured in bold
uh we'll talk about them a little bit
more in a moment but the il17
b receptor
and
a chemokine ligand called cxcl5 which
were both substantially upregulated
uh in
white minor endothelial cells in this
model
when we look at the top uh genes and we
look not just at those two but all of
the genes that were upregulated as a
disease signature what we see is this
that obesity drives a very specific
immune activation in endothelial cells
upregulating both il-17 il-25 and
chemokine signaling
and that's led us to focus on these
particular ligands which were among
those top genes driving this
molecular signal
specifically we created a proposed
signaling cascade in which il-17b
circulating in the bloodstream
then binds to its cognate receptor
il-17b which we showed is upregulated
and that triggers
the expression of cxcl5 which could have
both local paracrine effects in the
brain and also potentially be secreted
into the bloodstream
this chemokine ligand is important
because it acts on neutrophils and other
cells as a homing signal i am in danger
please come and find me
uh and uh and so in that context it can
act as a very important um uh indicator
of chronic injury
and we showed when we went back to brain
tissue that um
l17b is specifically that the receptor
is specifically upregulated in these
uh
damaged endothelial cells in in animals
on the high fat diet
and then
if you look specifically we also see
up regulation of this chemokine ligand
cxcl5 in brain blood vessels
and in fact we also can find cxcl5
present in human uh
brain in the endothelial cells shown
here in the brown and uh immune
chemistry signal specifically within the
blood vessels in patients with
cerebral small breast disease i'll show
some more data on that at the end
so using this signaling cascade uh you
know this was a proposed idea we showed
it's upregulated in the tissue
but does this make sense does it
actually lead to direct signaling and so
what we showed is that in animals on the
high fat diet you can find increased
levels of circulating cxcl5
and we showed that
here in the middle graph
but that doesn't really convince you
what we did was take
go to an in vitro model in which we took
human brain and ethereal cells and
stimulated them with various il-17
ligands there are five significant ones
a through e
and when we stimulated
human brain endothelial cells with these
various ligands we saw a very specific
increase in the secretion of cxcl5
response to multiple 17 ligands that
most robustly with the least variance
with il17b
indicating a novel signaling cascade in
human brain
between uh il17b
its cognate receptor and the secretion
of cxcl5
now
we wanted to test whether this system
was active
uh and and to move to an in vivo model
and so what we did then was take animals
on a high fat diet
and uh administer a function blocking
il-17b antibody we did that peripherally
through an ip injection and what it does
is block the uh gobbles up all the
il-17b such that it's not available to
its receptor and if our system is true
then we should reduce cxco5 levels and
in fact that's exactly what we see the
middle graph show the middle uh images
show that in when we administer control
igg we still see a robust upregulation
in green of cxcl5
and when we administer anti-il17b
antibodies we still see the receptors
upregulated but we've dropped the level
of cxcl5 in the cognate vessels
and we can use imaging techniques to
co-localize those together and then
measure that
intensity and you can see with the
anti-ill-17b treatment we dropped the
level of cxcl5 in the in the in the
tissue
now what does all that mean
uh well one of the important um
functions of the receptor
of this signaling cascade and and
the the function of the white matter is
to maintain myelin and the key cell that
does that is the stem cell referred to
as the oligodendrocyte progenitor cell
so we rationalize that if cxcl5 was
present
uh in in and functioning in a parakind
fashion it might
recruit oligarchic progenitor cells the
stem cell the major stem cell population
of the white matter
to these injured blood vessels
because that's its function of the
immune system as a homing migration
signal
maybe it works the same way to uh
modulate this stem cell and so that's
exactly what we see we did again two
experiments one where we administered
the function blocking until anti-il17b
and what you see there
and then the other method we used was to
over express the xcl5 in the vessel
using a targeted lentiviral approach
and when we do that
what we and then we measure the distance
of the alligator enzyme progenitor cell
from the blood vessel and what you can
see when we over express cxcl5 in normal
weight animals
we drive the opc to the vessel becomes
much closer as shown in the micrograph
two examples shown in the micrograph
when we block
uh il-17b signaling using the function
blocking il17b antibody
in the in control igg we see again opc
is
you know associated with the vessel as
shown here
and then when we block it we see the
opcs are maintaining their normal
distance uh an association with the
vessel but not
specifically grabbing on to it
uh as might be expected in those um
uh over expressing cxo5 and you can see
the uh the interesting heat map plot
there in the bottom left shows opc
distance from vessel the proportion of
cells that we that we quantitated
in the different dietary conditions and
so we can either
we can block that signal by disrupting
this signaling cascade
so
well i think what we what we've tried to
show and i think what this work
demonstrates is that we can go from
transcription
all the way to secretion both in vivo
and in the circulation i'd like to spend
the rest of the talk talking about how
we really wanted to show could this
disease this inflammatory signal be
associated with
um
a novel biomarker for the detection of
brain vascular injury
uh and so again taking the um
transcriptional signature and going all
the way from in the road all the way to
um secreted signals in human
so to do that we we wanted to turn
to
luminex and i'll tell you why it made a
lot of sense the first is we you know we
were looking for a novel signature and
so we came up with these these proteins
that we had identified in red that were
upregulated in our disease model
likely to be secreted based on existing
evidence or known biology
but you know to do that alone
didn't make a lot of sense we wanted to
anchor that
with
other biomarkers that were known to
associate
with
white matter injury and brain vascular
injury and so we chose
a wide series of those based on the
literature
and so it really had been was a
multiplex but you know we're talking now
about moving to human samples in which
specimens are rare hard to come by
and
and you want to maximize the ability to
use them and so what we did was work
with
with r d and biotechne and luminex to
create
a custom panel that would allow us to
measure many of these proteins in the
same serum specimen
so what we focused on then was
both these molecules in red that make up
this cerebrovascular endothelial injury
network including the il17 and cxco5
signaling
and then among these molecules that were
all independently associated with
brain vascular injury we noticed that
several of them also formed a network
that was focused on il-18 what we call
the peripheral inflammatory network or
um and
and then we set out to test those
luminex made again a lot of sense for
this kind of protein multiplexing
because we wanted to jam
all of these proteins into a single
assay so that we could use just a small
amount of serum or plasma and measure
all of these immune signals
and so and then the the idea was we
could use all of them together to create
a single uh score that represented each
of the two networks and talked about i
think this audience familiar with the
idea of multiplexing so i won't go into
that in great detail
so first uh to try to con
confirm
our cerebral endothelial injury network
shown on the right
we took advantage of a study we had done
at ucla
looking at patients who came in the
emergency room at risk for supervascular
disease with a potential diagnosis of
stroke
but not necessarily unconfirmed at the
time when they presented
and we we collected serum from those
patients
we performed mri in nearly 130 out of
200 subjects
we graded those mri scans for the degree
of white matter injury using a common
subjective scale
perform the multiplex luminex assay
on the serum
and then work to identify if we saw any
upregulation of our
inflammatory signals and what you can
see from that data is that we can
separate
a population
uh we have measurable levels of
il-17b
very low abundant cytokine so many
patients did not have measurable levels
and if you look at the the this is
plotted now against the level of cxcl5
and so we see is that in individuals in
all of our subjects those who have
measurable levels of il17b also have
substantially increased levels
of cxcl5 or significantly increased and
if you look specifically at those who
are diagnosed with an acute
microvascular stroke we also see that
this separates well there's a population
of il-17b cxcl5 positive patients
that can be distinguished
and if you look at those patients
and separate them based on the amount of
supervascular burden that they have
underlying
those with il-17b have substantially
increased
physical scores compared to
those who do not have measurable il-17b
this is a a common way a shift analysis
of looking at an ordinal scale which the
modified physical scale is it's
if you have zero you have no white
matter brain lesions you've had six you
have substantial and you can see that um
there's first of all no normal patients
in the l17b positive grouping
and so there's a substantial shift in
the number of patients who have modest
white minor hyperintensities and in a
separate population of human subjects
we showed that they're uh in the
post-mortem specimens with vascular
disease
they have a substantial labeling for
cxcl5 in the brain blood vessels and
that's plotted in the bottom right
now we wanted to anchor that again
against the existing data and
again the molecules that form this
peripheral inflammatory network centered
on a different cytokine isle 18
that's a pro-inflammatory cytokine
each of these had been independently
associated with white matter lesions
mostly in large cohort studies
but we wanted to know whether that what
we had a second strong indicator
suggesting that the inflammation was a
key driver of uh uh white matter injury
and so we turned to our colleagues at
ucsf we've been maintaining a population
of uh
patients who were
at risk for cognitive impairment but
without known supervascular disease and
did a similar study in which we
collected
plasma or serum biospecimens as well as
advanced imaging and in this case we
were able to do research grade three
tesla mri along with diffusion tensor
uh imaging in in a significant number of
those patients and then we looked for
whether this inflammatory network
as measured by the multiplex luminex
assay could associate with those mri
indicators
and
just a brief note another advantage of
the limitex platform is that it's highly
accurate and so we observed in in the
combined measurement of both studies
very few subjects have high coefficients
of variance
in technical duplicate or triplicate
they
perform extremely well we've tested this
across different plates different users
and even different devices
uh uh showing that we have very low
aggregate uh variants between assays and
it can be performed in the serum
specimen
uh
or plasma specimen less than 50
microliters
and so what you see when we look at that
peripheral inflammatory network
if you boil it down to a single
inflammatory composite score
what we find is that it associates very
uh significantly with um known risk
factors for cerebrovascular disease like
a prior stroke high blood pressure
diabetes or hyperlipidemia and in fact
if you if you have more one or more of
these conditions your risk or your
measurement of inflammatory
of the inflammatory composite score goes
up uh
accordingly so it nearly doubles every
time you add an additional vascular risk
factor
uh and
importantly it associates very clearly
with
these mri measures of both white matter
hyperintensities as shown in the middle
uh the middle mri graphic
and then also with a measure of cerebral
edema called free water
shown on the right and here we're
looking just at dichotomized patients
above or below median on the composite
score and what you see on the heat map
on the left is those patients
participating in the study
their level of each analyte as ordered
by their degree of white matter
hyperintensity and so you can see that
two important factors here one is that
you can clearly see that the composite
score associates well with the detection
of these white matter hyper intensities
and moreover
the score the composite score is not
driven by a single analyte if you have
high levels of one inlay you're likely
to have them on all
all six
uh and the bottom plots show the
correlation between
uh white minor hyperintensities on the
left and b and then c the free white the
free water measurement uh
on dti
uh so
uh we had really strong evidence that
this was a second uh a
biomarker panel that can pick up a brain
white matter injury uh we went and
turned back to that ucla aspire study
to validate that idea and so uh here
again we we had this uh robust data set
of patients at risk for pseudovascular
disease and what we did here was um with
this work since we were attempting to
validate it uh we took the entire
luminex uh custom platform that we had
generated and did a principal components
analysis and asked what of the of the
biomarkers the 13 plus biomarkers we
were looking at which ones associated in
this study with the physique its grading
of white matter hyperintensities and
what you can see is in the pca one
factor jumped out significantly
and if you plot that factor against the
the already consolidated known six
analyte uh inflammatory composite score
you get this very tight association so
that scores is mostly driven by the
components of the ics
um and uh let's see here we this slide i
don't think quite showed up the way i
intended it to
but if you go back and look at the
aspire study
you can and grade the uh mris based on
the physical scale into the three known
categories mild moderate to severe you
can see that the ics or inflammatory
composite score goes up significantly in
patients who have
um
known white matter disease leading to a
nearly 94 specificity
for the detection of this silent brain
vascular injury i intended to show you
two mri scores to show you the dichotomy
here between these two
types of mri patterns based on the ics
score
but we had some technical difficulties
so with these tools in hand
we're now going to be applying these to
several of the studies that i mentioned
earlier including
this one discovery this is a um really a
what will be a landmark study to
identify how stroke influences the risk
of dementia
which is at least in part driven by
these
underlying ischemic white matter injury
lesions
and we'll be applying the ics
to patients nearly 2 000 patients uh uh
who are part of this large cohort
and i think importantly we'll be able to
discern
key ethnic differences in the
burden of vascular disease and the risk
in which
they they also manifest these high
levels of biomarkers and what how they
associate with the cognitive impairment
that portends that and that's important
because i think it'll give us a window
into potential treatment opportunities
to reduce the risk
of carbon impairment associated with
brain vascular injury
um i'll conclude there and we'll leave
hopefully a few minutes for questions
um i hope i've shown you that there's an
important role for inflammation in the
detect
in the pathogenesis and also the
detection of silent brain vascular
injury
i try to show you the convincing
evidence that this is a common and
progressive disease that has significant
risk for long-term brain health
including increasing the risk of stroke
and dementia
i tried to show you evidence from both
the clinical literature as well as our
laboratory evidence that chronic
vascular risk factors
drive brain vascular information in a
way that could theoretically be
therapeutically targeted as we were able
to reduce that using an antibody
blocking approach
i'll also try to emphasize the
important role that analytically
reliable biomarkers
are a key component of therapeutic
development to distinguish the
contribution
of various injury signals in the brain
and finally that our six analyte
inflammatory composite score is a really
robust multi-analyte measure of silent
brain vascular injury and associates
with preclinical cerebral edema
and i think that tool may be
particularly useful
as we try to move this field forward
towards therapeutics
most of the work i show you today uh is
that of a former postdoc gwangju zhao
who is now an industry job back in china
uh and um you know we do a lot of work
but we also managed to get out uh in the
la thought and have some fun
occasionally i'm very grateful to many
collaborators at ucla and other places
who are listed you can follow the lab
and its progress on twitter and we have
many uh uh
grant funding support that i'm very
appreciative for
i'll stop there and
hopefully we'll have a few minutes for
questions
thank you so much dr hinman for that
informative presentation and we will
start that live q a portion of the
webinar now if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions from our audience
members
dr hammond do specific cardiovascular
risk factors like hypertension or
diabetes drive different inflammatory
cascades
it's a great question suzy i mean i
think
uh you know our work from from our basic
science model suggests that there's a
significant contribution of il17
uh in the setting of obesity now obesity
is a difficult one because it does
elevate a number of different
um
modestly elevated number of different
relevant uh cardiovascular risk factors
but in folks who say have high blood
pressure but don't you know aren't
particularly overweight uh there may be
uh specific uh signaling cascades and
inflammatory pathways that are unique to
that we have ongoing work in the lab
trying to address that using the same
model system that i showed
you thank you so much now what is the
advantage of luminix over other
technologies in multiplex assays
yeah
you know we there are many options now
out there different platforms
many will migrate to different ones
based on the
availability of different antibodies but
to me as a physician scientist the
reason i like luminex so much is that
they've already done a lot of the hard
work to get their diagnostics uh through
to the fda and so that that provides a
relatively easy path for
um you know clinical translation and and
we're working in that area as well
thank you so much it looks like we have
one more question coming in how far away
are we from therapeutics for brain
vascular injury
yeah that's another good question i
think um you know
most of the effort and and funding that
i showed you is really focused on
slightly upstream of therapeutics but
it's been really driven
to try to get us to
a clinical trial ready system uh you
know i mentioned in the talk how this is
a really fuzzy clinical area people are
you know patients are getting these
lesions and developing symptoms sort of
uh you know in a progressive way but in
a
you know not very time locked or
um you know somewhat abstract way and so
the biomarkers play a really important
role then in identifying uh who has what
and who might be a candidate for a
therapy so i think within the next five
years
i think you'll see
large
scale
therapeutic treatment trials begin
to target uh vascular cardiac impairment
dementia
using some of the tools that we've been
working to develop including some that i
mentioned today
dr hammond thank you for your time and
for your important research
do you have any closing remarks you
would like to add to our audience before
we go
uh no uh
not particularly just uh i hope
everyone's well and um i look forward to
being able to do this kind of work and
this kind of meeting uh in person soon
thank you again dr himan and thank you
for your time and before we go i'd also
like to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and i'd also like to thank
luminix and lab roots for today's
seminar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during on our
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years till april of 2023 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care and
everyone stay healthy bye